[Musique]
la situation sanitaire
et au cours d
jour en moyenne 32 1978 test positif à
la coved 19 ont été déclarées chaque
jour et depuis quelques jours le nombre
de contaminations n'augmente plus mais
bien sûr il ne faut pas crier victoire
trop vite parce que ce plateau reste
quand même très élevé
les élèves y est dense
cette interview au télégramme olivier
ferrand se dit favorable 1 déconfinement
territorialisée en clair les levée des
restrictions seraient différentes en
fonction de la situation épidémique
nous avons toujours été partisan d'une
approche territoriale c'est qu'on n'a
jamais compris qu on applique le même
traitement un département comme les
alpes maritimes un département comme la
cause les côtes d'armor par exemple dans
l'ouest de la france où le virus ou le
taux d'incidence étaient cinq six voire
sept fois moins important parce qu'un
responsable les pieds dans les gravats
d'un édifice qui s'effondre vient vous
expliquer laborieusement qui fait ce
qu'il peut
cela n'est guère rassurant et s'il
promet le droit à une vie paisible
force est de constater que son mandat à
vue généralement les français glisser
vers une vie pénible
ça fait 40 ans qu'il ya 70% de familles
monoparentales cada drogue partout et
que les gens très courageux qui essaie
de s'en sortir c'est grâce à emmanuel
macron qu'on met 300 millions d'euros
pour refaire totalement sky et gérald
darmanin et vous allez dire prise en
arrêt depuis qu'il est responsable de
cet état je vais vous faire écouter
jusqu'à ce que sur des galets la légende
ne met plus les enfants dans le même
quartier et ce qui est vraiment dommage
monsieur présidence j'ai mon fils qu'est
habitants il m'a demandé si pied le
groupe rhénan de pia existait vraiment
c'est que dans le livre
tellement qu'ils aiment manque de mixité
dans le quartier felix 6 7 ans vous avez
des enfants qui n'ont jamais rencontré
un pierre de leur vie et vous avez aussi
des enfants qui à l'âge de 6-7 ans n'ont
jamais rencontré un mohamed de leur vie
où une fête strictement et je pense que
cette mixité sociale cette mère elle
elle dit tout elle est filmée de dos de
sorte qu'on voit toutes les réactions du
président regard gêné qui s'échappe sur
sa gauche existe vraiment il ya des gens
qui a conquis
puis il hausse les sourcils stupéfait
par ce qu'il est en train d'entendre et
l'évocation d'un prénom un pierre vie
dit non au puy ce pierre destrem ans il
ya des gens qui s'appellent pierre et
donc il ne l'a pas découvert et c'est ce
que je porte au sein du gouvernement
avec d'autres pour du logement social
partout du logement social diversité et
que le logement concours à cette mixité
qui finalement est demandée par tous
c'est une femme comme vous l'avez dit
qu'ils étaient voilées cas mais le
foulard et c'est elle qui demandait la
mixité sociale celle qui remerciait les
forces de police de lutter contre les
stupéfiants
c'est elle qui s'attaquait aux barbus
elle l'a dit elle même vous avez passé
qu'un extrait d'abord moi j'ai confiance
dans la république lorsque neil mac est
né au maroc elle l'a dit elle même qui
est arrivé à l'âge de 7 ans en france
dit moi je veux la mixité sociale dans
mon quartier je veux des paulines il y
en a pas comme on lutte concrètement
contre les ghettos nous à la région on a
pris une décision très simple nous ne
finançons plus un logement social dans
un quartier où il y en a déjà plus de
30%
ça veut dire qu'on a mis un plafond anti
gay taux de 30% de logements très
sociaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est de confronter ces zones rouges et
de les transformer en quartier sans
relou jeudi en clin d'oeil les qsr les
quartiers sans relou et sa sortie c'est
pareil des habitants du quartier de la
paillade sont en colère contre le
président d'abord du président tchadien
idriss deby il a succombé à ses
blessures après avoir été touché lors
d'affrontement avec des rebelles dans le
nord du pays
la france perd un ami courageux selon
l'élysée idriss deby qui venait d'être
réélu était un allié essentiel dans la
lutte contre les djihadistes au sahel